Bon, tout d'abord, permettez-moi de remercier Emeka -- en fait,
TED Global -- pour l'organisation de cette conférence.
Cette conférence va devenir la plus importante
de ce début de 21ème siècle.
Vous croyez qu'un gouvernement africain organiserait une telle conférence ?
Vous imaginez l'Union Africaine organiser une telle conférence ?
Même pour cela, ils feraient appel à l'aide étrangère.
J'aimerais également rendre hommage aux TED Fellows
June Arunga, James Shikwati, Andrew et les autres TED Fellows.
Ce sont eux que j'appelle la Génération des Guépards.
Cette génération Guépard est une nouvelle sorte d'africains
qui ne s'en laissent pas compter sur la corruption.
Ils comprennent ce que la responsabilité et la démocratie veulent dire.
Ils n'attendront pas que les gouvernements fassent quelque chose pour eux.
C'est cela, la Génération Guépard.
Et le salut de l'Afrique repose sur les épaules de ces guépards.
Par opposition, bien sûr, nous avons la génération Hippopotame.
(Rires)
La génération des Hippopotames sont les élites au pouvoir
Ils sont vautrés dans leur marigot intellectuel
se plaignant du colonialisme et de l'impérialisme
mais sans jamais bouger une oreille.
Si vous leur demandez de réformer les économies,
ils ne les réformeront pas
parce qu'ils profitent de ce statu quo pourri.
Pourtant, il y a beaucoup d'africains très en colère,
en colère à cause de la condition dans laquelle se trouve l'Afrique.
Nous parlons ici d'un continent qui n'est pas pauvre.
Il est riche de ressources minérales, de ressources minérales naturelles.
Mais cette richesse minérale de l'Afrique n'est pas utilisée
pour sortir son peuple de la pauvreté.
C'est cela qui met beaucoup d'africains très en colère
D'une certaine façon, l'Afrique vit une tragédie et sous plus d'une forme.
Il y a une autre tragédie qui dure, cette tragédie est
qu'il y a tellement de gens, tellement de gouvernements,
tellement d'organisations qui veulent aider en Afrique
ils ne comprennent pas.
Attention, nous ne disons pas : n'aidez pas l'Afrique.
Aider l'Afrique est noble.
Mais l'aide à l'Afrique s'est transformée en une scène de l'absurde.
C'est l'aveugle conduisant l'égaré.
(Rires)
Il nous faut comprendre certaines choses.
La sébile africaine a une fuite.
Saviez-vous que 40% de la richesse créée en Afrique
n'est pas investie ici en Afrique ?
Elle est prise à l'Afrique.
C'est ce que dit la Banque Mondiale.
Regardez la sébile de l'Afrique.
Elle fuit terriblement.
Il y a ceux qui pensent que nous devrions y verser plus d'argent,
plus d'aide dans cette sébile qui fuit.
Où sont les fuites ?
La corruption à elle seule coûte 148 milliards de dollars par an.
Bon, mettons cela de côté.
La fuite des capitaux hors d'Afrique, 80 milliards par an.
Mettons cela de côté.
Prenons l'importation de nourriture.
Chaque année, l'Afrique dépense 20 milliards de dollars pour importer de la nourriture
Additionnons simplement tout ça, toutes ces fuites.
C'est beaucoup plus que les 50 milliards que Tony Blair voudrait lever pour l'Afrique.
Maintenant, retournons dans les années 1960, l'Afrique ne faisait pas que se nourrir,
elle exportait aussi de la nourriture.
Plus maintenant.
Nous savons que quelque chose a fondamentalement mal tourné
Vous le savez, je le sais, mais ne perdons pas de temps, notre temps,
à parler de ces erreurs, nous y passerions toute la journée.
Avançons et passons au chapitre suivant.
Et c'est le sujet précis de cette conférence, le chapitre suivant.
Le chapitre suivant commence surtout par cette question
fondamentale que nous devons nous poser
"Qui voulons-nous aider en Afrique ?"
Il y a le peuple, et il y a le gouvernement ou dirigeants.
Maintenant, l'orateur avant moi, le précédent orateur,
Idris Mohamed, a indiqué que
nous avons eu des dirigeants consternants en Afrique.
Cette façon de le dire est, selon moi, encore trop charitable.
(Rires)
Je participe à un forum de discussion sur Internet,
un forum de discussion africain,
et je leur demandais, "Depuis 1960, nous avons eu exactement
204 chefs d'Etats Africain depuis 1960".
Et je leur ai demandé de me citer ne serait-ce que 20 bons dirigeants,
juste 20 bons leaders -- peut-être
essaierez-vous de relever ce défi-là vous-même.
Je leur ai demandé seulement 20 noms.
Tout le monde a mentionné Nelson Mandela, bien sûr.
Kwame Nkrumah, Nyerere, Kenyatta -- quelqu'un a cité Idi Amin
(Rires)
J'ai laissé passer.
Ce que je veux dire, c'est qu'ils n'ont pas dépassé 15.
Même s'ils avaient pu m'en citer 20,
qu'est-ce que cela nous apprend ?
20 sur 204, cela veut dire que la majorité, la grande majorité
des dirigeants africains, a fait défaut au peuple.
Et regardez-les, cette brochette de dirigeants post-coloniaux,
cet assortiment de guignols militaires.
ces socialistes aux comptes en Suisse, ces requins de libérateurs,
cette élite de vampires, ces révolutionnaires charlatans.
(Applaudissements)
Ce leadership-là est très éloigné des chefs de la tradition
que les africains ont connue depuis des siècles.
La deuxième fausse promesse que nous faisons
quand nous cherchons à aider l'Afrique
c'est que parfois, nous pensons qu'il existe quelque chose qui s'appellerait
"gouvernement" en Afrique qui prendrait soin de son peuple,
servirait les intérêts du peuple et représenterait le peuple.
Un chef du Lesotho a eu cette phrase :
"Ici au Lésotho, nous avons deux problèmes
les rats et le gouvernement."
(Rires)
Ce que vous et moi entendons par gouvernement
n'existe pas dans de nombreux pays africains.
En fait, ce que nous appelons gouvernements sont des Etats vampires.
Vampires parce qu'ils aspirent
la vitalité économique de leur peuple.
Le gouvernement est le problème en Afrique.
L'Etat vampire, c'est le gouvernement
(Applaudissements)
qui a été piraté par une bande de bandits et d'escrocs
qui utilise les institutions de l'Etat pour s'enrichir eux,
leurs copains, leur tribu, et exclure tous les autres.
Les plus riches en Afrique sont les chefs d'Etats et leurs ministres,
et très souvent, le chef de la bande est le chef de l'Etat lui-même.
D'où tirent-ils leur argent ?
En créant de la richesse ?
Non.
En le râtissant sur le dos de leur peuple qui souffre.
Ce n'est pas de la création de richesses -- c'est de la redistribution de richesses.
Le troisième point fondamental qu'il nous faut identifier
c'est que si nous voulons aider l'Afrique,
nous devons savoir où se situe le peuple africain.
Prenez une économie africaine.
Une économie africaine peut se décomposer en trois secteurs.
Il y a le secteur moderne, il y a le secteur informel
et le secteur traditionnel.
Le secteur moderne est le domaine des élites.
C'est le siège du gouvernement.
Dans nombre de pays africains, le secteur moderne est perdu.
Il dysfonctionne.
C’est une valse racoleuse de systèmes venus d’ailleurs,
que les élites elles-mêmes ne comprennent pas.
C’est la source de beaucoup des problèmes de l’Afrique,
une source dont découlent les luttes de pouvoir politiques
qui retombent ensuite sur les secteurs informels et traditionnels,
fauchant des vies innocentes.
Alors le secteur moderne, bien sûr,
est l'endroit où une grande part de l'aide au développement et des ressources est allée.
Plus de 80 % du développement de la Côte d'Ivoire
est allé au secteur moderne.
Les autres secteurs, les secteurs informel et traditionnel,
sont les endroits où se trouve la majorité du peuple africain.
Les vrais gens de l'Afrique -- c'est là que vous les trouverez.
Alors, c'est une évidence de bon sens,
si vous souhaitez aider le peuple, vous allez là où se trouve le peuple.
Mais ce n'est pas ce que nous avons fait.
En fait,
nous avons négligé les secteurs informel et traditionnel.
Maintenant, le secteur traditionnel est celui où l'Afrique produit son agriculture,
ce qui est l'une des raisons pour laquelle l'Afrique ne peut se nourrir elle-même,
et c'est pour cela qu'elle doit importer de la nourriture.
Donc, vous ne pouvez pas développer l'Afrique en ignorant
les secteurs informel et traditionnel.
Et vous ne pouvez développer les secteurs informel et traditionnel
sans une compréhension de terrain du fonctionnement de ces deux secteurs.
Ces deux secteurs, permettez-moi de les décrire,
ils ont leur propres institutions autochtones.
La première est le système politique.
Traditionnellement, les africains détestent les gouvernements -- ils haïssent la tyrannie.
Si vous examinez leurs systèmes traditionnels,
les africains organisent leurs Etats selon deux types.
Le premier appartient à ces sociétés ethniques
qui pensent qu'un Etat est nécessairement tyrannique,
alors, elle refusent d'avoir quoi que ce soit à voir
avec une autorité centrale.
Ces sociétés sont les Ibo, les Somali, les Kikuyus,
par exemple -- elles n'ont aucun chef.
Les autres groupes ethniques, qui avaient des chefs
s'assuraient qu'ils entouraient bien les chefs
de conseils et de conseils et de conseils
afin des les empêcher d'abuser de leur pouvoir.
Dans la tradition Ashanti, par example,
le chef ne peut prendre aucune décision
sans l'assentiment simultané du conseil des anciens.
Sans le conseil, le chef ne peut pas faire passer une loi,
et si le chef ne gouverne pas selon la volonté de son peuple
il est destitué.
S'il ne l'est pas, le peuple abandonne le chef,
s'en va ailleurs et crée une autre implantation.
Et même si vous prenez les anciens empires africains,
ils étaient tous organisés autour d'un principe précis --
le principe de confédération,
qui se caractérise par un fort transfert d'autorité,
une décentralisation du pouvoir.
C'est ce que je viens de vous décrire,
c'est une part de l'héritage politique autochtone de l'Afrique.
Maintenant, comparons cela avec les systèmes modernes,
les élites gouvernantes établies en Afrique.
C'est totalement différent.
Dans le système économique de l'Afrique traditionnelle,
les moyens de production sont propriété privée.
Ils appartiennent à des familles étendues.
Voyez-vous, en Occident, l'unité économique et sociale
est l'individu.
L'Américain dira, "je suis parce que je suis,
et je peux sacrément bien faire tout ce que je veux quand je veux."
L'accent est sur le "je".
En Afrique, les africains disent, "je suis, car nous sommes".
Le "nous" suggère la communauté -- le système de famille élargie.
Le système de famille étendue regroupe les ressources de ses membres.
Elles possèdent des fermes. Elles décident quoi faire, quoi produire.
Elles ne prennent pas leurs ordres auprès de leurs chefs --
elles décident elles-mêmes ce qu'elles vont faire.
Et quand elles produisent leurs récoltes, elles vendent le surplus
sur des marchés.
Quand elles font un profit, elles le conservent pour elles,
il n’est pas destiné à leur être confisqué par le chef.
Donc, en résumé, ce que nous avions dans l'Afrique traditionnelle
c'était un système d'économie de marché.
Il y avait des marchés en Afrique
avant que les colonialistes ne posent le pied sur le continent.
Tombouctou était une grande ville de marché.
Kano, Salaga -- toutes l'étaient.
Même si vous allez maintenant en Afrique de l'Ouest, vous remarquerez
que l'activité des marchés a toujours été dominée par les femmes.
Il est donc logique que cette partie soit
celle du marché.
Le marché n'est pas étranger à l'Afrique.
Ce que les africains pratiquaient était une forme différente de capitalisme,
mais par la suite, après l'indépendance, tout d'un coup,
les marchés, le capitalisme devinrent une institution occidentale,
et les dirigeants dirent que les africains étaient prêts pour le socialisme.
Balivernes.
Même vu ainsi, quelle sorte de socialisme ont-ils pratiqué ?
Leur socialisme était une forme assez remarquable
de socialisme avec compte en Suisse,
qui permettait aux chefs des Etats et à leurs ministres
de violer et piller les dépôts de l'Afrique,
les excédents de trésorerie déposés en Suisse.
Ce n'est pas le genre de système que les africains avaient connu pendant des siècles.
Alors que faire maintenant ?
Revenir aux institutions autochtones africaines,
et c'est là que nous demandons aux guépards d'aller dans les secteurs informels,
les secteurs traditionnels --
c'est là que se trouve le peuple africain.
Et j'aimerais vous montrer une rapide video
sur le secteur informel, sur la construction de bateaux
vers lequel j'ai personnellement cherché à mobiliser
l'investissement de la Diaspora.
Pouvez-vous la passer s'il vous plaît ?
Les hommes vont pêcher sur ces petits bateaux.
Oui, c'est une entreprise.
Celle d'une entrepreneur Ghanéen local, utilisant son propre capital.
Il ne reçoit aucune subvention du gouvernement,
et il est en train de construire un second et plus gros bateau.
Un plus grand bateau signifie que plus de poisson sera pris et débarqué.
Cela signifie qu'il sera capable d'employer plus de Ghanéens.
Cela veut dire également qu'il pourra générer de la richesse.
Et alors cela produira ce que les économistes appellent
des effets externes sur l'économie locale.
Tout ce que vous avez à faire, tout ce que les élites doivent faire,
est de déplacer ce chantier dans un endroit clos de murs
de façon à ce que les opérations soient plus efficientes.
Mais, ce n'est pas seulement ce secteur informel --
il y a aussi la médecine traditionnelle.
80% des africains ont toujours recours à la médecine traditionnelle.
Le secteur moderne de la santé s'est totalement effondré
Bon, ceci est un domaine -- je veux dire qu'il y a un un trésor de richesse
dans le domaine de la médecine traditionnelle.
C'est là que nous devons mobiliser les africains,
dans la Diaspora en particulier.
Nous devons également mobiliser les africains de la Diaspora,
pas seulement pour aller vers les secteurs traditionnels mais
aussi vers l'agriculture et aussi d'instiller le changement de l'intérieur.
Nous avons pu mobiliser les Ghanéens de la Diaspora
pour initier le changement au Ghana et y amener la démocratie.
Et je sais qu'avec les guépards, nous pouvons reprendre possession de l'Afrique
village par village.
Merci beaucoup.
Applaudissements